- We'll let's start with
my first guest now,
she's a actress and
director and you know her
from that 70s show on
"Orange is the new Black"
now she has a new bestselling book called
"You and I as Mothers A Raw
and Honest Guide to Motherhood"
It's Laura Prepon.
- Hi
(laughing)
Oh my Gosh, hello I'm such a big fan.
You're so talented.
- Oh my God, you too,
Thank you so much for having me on.
- No, thank you, I saw your,
I just don't ever see pictures
I'm never in the limelight ever
and I just see you in
my head as a redhead.
So I'm like seeing and I was like,
"I know Lauren Prepon
but this is not her."
And I was like, you're
like such a different human
with dark hair, it's beautiful.
- So thank you, it's so weird, I mean,
I did this because for
"Orange is the New Black"
- Yeah
- And then when we--
I was pregnant when we wrapped
and then I couldn't change my hair color.
And then I just gave
birth a few months ago
and now it's a pandemic and now
I can't get my hair changed.
- Here in my, I know my roots
so I'm just like whatever.
So how is it going though?
Speaking of "Orange is the New Black"
was that any kind of
prep for quarantine time?
Coz you know we are stuck in one place.
- Yeah, I mean, honestly we...
I mean, look, I was
already pretty prepared,
just with the whole that my
baby was coming and everything,
we were already planning
on isolating and yeah,
I mean I don't know if "Orange"
really prepared me but,
- Yeah
- is that you know,
there are so many of us
together all the time
but in terms of you know, the
fact that I just had a baby
that really prepared you know,
the fact that we were already
planning on isolating,
definitely I think made the
transition a little smoother.
We try to laugh when we
can, it's hard Kelly.
- Oh my gosh, you know
humor has gotten me through many times.
So I'm with you with that.
But I hear that you're
to get you through times,
we have something in common you love games
like you're competitive.
Do you play poker?
Did I hear right that you play poker?
- That was another life but yes.
- Oh, it's the time when you were cool
and had a life before kids and everything?
(laughing)
I always say that I'm like,
"Oh it was not as cool and I did things."
(laughter)
- I used to play so much.
I mean, I played in
the World Series twice.
I was on the cover
- That's crazy!
- No, I was I was obsessed. I actually,
I was on the cover of a poker magazine.
- Wow, yeah!
- I was playing
like I was totally--
- But you're an actor, though.
So you're really good at bluffing so
- I did pretty well.
I was really into it.
But now with kids,
I don't have time to
go sit at a card table.
- Oh my gosh, no, I feel you.
Her new book y'all is called
"You and I as Mothers a Raw and
Honest Guide to Motherhood."
I feel like there's so
many books out there
and so many guides for
but there's not many,
like I love your title.
And I know the vibe of it
being like raw and real
and like the ups and downs of everything.
I feel like everything doesn't
prepare you for all of that.
So what made you want to open up
the way you did in your new book
'cause you're very honest
about things that maybe people
would never tell people.
- Yeah, I honestly for me
I felt like there were all
these books about pregnancy
and there were all these books, you know,
leading you up to when
you become a mother,
but I didn't find any resources for me
once I became a mother.
And I was like, what about
the rest of my life, you know?
So for me I felt like
there really wasn't
anything out there for us
and there wasn't a resource for me.
So I wrote the book I was looking for you,
I interviewed a bunch of women in it
to speak to all these common themes
so the reader can find
someone to relate to
'cause we all go through similar things,
even if we are in our
different stages of motherhood
it's not this isn't a postpartum book
it's for mothers of all ages, yeah.
- No, I love that it's really honest.
I think that that's important
I also think it's important
that you're just writing just being a mom,
especially a young mom of young kids, like
it's really important you
have some sort of mom squad,
like you have some like,
or even a friend squad,
they don't have to be all moms
but just to understand like
where you're coming from
and to have that kind of,
I don't know that bond,
like, can you talk about that
in the book about moms squads, right?
- Yeah. I mean, I, you know,
just like you said, like
it's just really important especially now
with all of the quarantine
and self-isolation.
I mean, people are starting
to go back out again,
but nothing like we did of course.
And with social distancing, I
find that already being a mom
can feel isolating and you know,
especially now with
everything we're going through
with the pandemic it's
even more isolating.
So anything you can do to
help build that community,
is so important.
And I write about that
because that's something
I really had to learn.
But now as a mother,
I do feel like it's really
important to have that,
whether whoever that is for you,
whoever your community is for you.
- So what advice, like what kind of advice
has your mom's squad
given you like personally,
like you've kind of I struggled with.
- Well, when I had my,
for, you know, my baby,
I just had a boy, but
when I had my daughter,
who's now about two and a half,
I went back to work at six weeks
and I was directing by the
time she was four months old.
And I remember, talking to
Mila about being a working mom
and she gave me a really cool
piece of advice, which was
when you talk to your kids,
like about going to work,
she's never like, "Oh, that
sucks, mommy has to go to work."
She always puts a really
positive spin on it
and she's always like,
"Mommy has to go to work.
Isn't that awesome?"
Like she puts a really
positive thing on it
so that her children associate
positivity with work.
And that's something I
thought was really cool,
especially cause I was struggling so much
with going back to work so quickly.
And you know, another example
that kind of feeds into
the mom, guilt of it all
is quality over quantity.
One of my friends, Amber
Tamblyn shared that with me,
'cause her daughter's a
little older than mine
and you can be with your family,
but if you're on your
phone or fielding emails or
- you're not present
- on social media,
whatever you're doing, you're not present.
You're not even there.
So it's like
quality over quantity when
you're with your family,
you make it really quality
time and really be present
and are there that's something
that really helped me too,
it's just when I am with my family,
having very quality time,
don't try to work while
I'm with my family.
That's something that has
really helped me a lot, so
- Yeah.
- That's great.
- So you opened up in the book about
like speaking of being
personal from the beginning,
that's what I loved about
how raw and real you are.
'Cause I feel like sometimes
that's few and far between
with people and the public eye.
But you had to make an impossible decision
during a pregnancy.
And I have known people that
have had the same scenario.
So what happened with this situation?
How did you cope with it?
'Cause it's a, that's a
big thing to open up about.
- Well, what's interesting is that
when I first we had to make a decision
because we found out once we
got into the second trimester,
by the way, but it's usually, you know,
once you get into that,
you're like "I'm in the clear"
- Yeah
- But we found out
when we were into our second
trimester, that there were,
some pretty devastating health problems.
And that the baby was
at risk I was at risk,
the baby probably wouldn't survive
and then I was at risk
for carrying any longer.
And we really weren't in a position to...
the writing was on the wall
there was nothing we could do.
And it might, my husband and I often say
that was the worst day of our
lives, making that decision
and it's once I went through it,
I was really mad at my body and myself
like I thought I did
something to cause it,
which I didn't,
but you just are trying
so hard to find an answer.
And I found that once I went through that,
I started finding out
about these other women
who've gone through similar losses
and nobody was talking about it,
- Yeah
- but I felt that
it was really important to write about it
because I wanted other people
to be able to feel safe,
to share their story.
And the fact that I wrote about it,
I can't tell you how many
people have reached out.
- I can't imagine
- explaining
how much it's helped them
and now they're able to
vocalize what they went through
or they feel seen and heard
and it's something that was
really hard for me to share,
but I'm so glad I did, because
it really helped again,
built this community
and made it safer for
people to talk about.
- Yeah, and I mean, I'm
one who loves therapy,
so I just sometimes like
learning and they were like,
just saying it aloud helps you heal,
like just saying it out loud
and not keeping it inside,
and it just kinda building up like
saying it aloud helps the person saying it
just as much as somebody
connecting to the message
and feeling the same way.
So it's very brave and it's very cool
and you're very strong woman.
- Thank you.
- All right, well
thank you so much
and Laura's book everybody
"You and I as mothers A Raw
and Honest Guide to Motherhood"
is available now.
Go and get it I promise
all you mamas out there are mamas-to-be.
It's a good one. Go find that one.